Well, welcome everybody to another Zoom call. We're going to try to answer as many questions as possible.
Reminder to go to our blogs if you're searching for an immediate answer for anything.
Go to coderspletic.com. Search in the search bar. We have a web page or a blog page.
We have a little 1200 different that you may find we answer to something.
Great a new blog on some research. I have been doing recently that maybe an interest to
anybody who has cancer and done so look at the blog that I created recently about
heartacid pro-oxidated agents to help maybe like cancer. I think that might be helpful to anybody
as kids. Reminder also to look at our member site pretty enough so that you can schedule your
old appointment on the self-schedule page on our website or the member site. Just schedule a regular
phone call for most people unless you want to go over a lab. Just like to go over a lab and please
schedule a Zoom call so that I can share my screen makes it a little easier. First question,
I just did a cheek swap. A chiropractor also muscle tests the first supplements and he wants
me to take nine role of the iodine. That's a product of standard process. The latest muscle test
with you said no. That's supplement. I'm confused now. There are many sources say iodine is good for
healing breast cancer please explain. Yeah well you can have differences in testing so you're just
going to have to make a decision on your own when you have a difference of opinion from two
different practitioners. It didn't test well with you this time so that's why I put no.
I don't give something just because you know there's there's there's several books written on iodine
in breast cancer. Well you know you have to be careful you have to be careful with everything right
but you have to be careful with iodine because iodine any long term use of iodine is
you know you have a much higher chance of developing Hashimoto's when you have an auto
new disease that's cool morbidity with a cancer it makes trading the cancer even more difficult so
you know even if it muscle even if iodine muscle tested well I would still personally recommend doing
a complete thyroid panel. Now you could do a complete thyroid panel within our complete wellness
panel because it's in that but a complete thyroid panel remember it contains T3, T4,
reverse T3, TSH, TPO antibodies, ethyroglobin and antibodies at the very least so getting that done
would be wise if those were all normal your thyroid was all normal then you could persuade first seed
with caution but if you have any type of primary hypothyroidism there's been studies down that if you have
primary hyper hypothyroidism and you take iodine it's almost 100% guaranteed. I mean literally
in this one study in Japan it's 354 women with primary hypothyroidism put them on iodine
within three to six months every single patient and Hashimoto's so every single patient will be
primary hypothyroidism is diagnosed as someone with low thyroid but does not have any auto immune
they don't have any inflammation or TPO antibodies or thyroid antibodies for every single person because
thyroid is so specific or because iodine is so specific to the thyroid it can stimulate an
immune response to the thyroid especially if you're taking a bunch of immune stimulators for cancer
you're using immune stimulators to try to kill your cancer and then you take iodine it can
stimulate an immune response to the thyroid that's how it ends up of working that you adapt
to developing antibodies to this thyroid so I would just be cautious in that you can do what you want
you know and everything you're going to have to pray about your decision but I don't think
we'd have good practitioners if they didn't have some disagreements but some things
okay next question can you please explain how blood plasma transfusions work are they good for
cancer patients so well there is a difference in whether you're you know if you're doing a
blood transfusion or low red blood cells that you're going to do a whole blood transfusion or you're
going to do packed red blood cell transfusion to help with anidemia that would be common with a person
with cancer if they have anidemia so they have you know greatly reduced hemoglobin usually that
is the deciding factor and whether they're going to get a transfusion or not you won't get just a
straight plasma transfusion you get a full blood transfusion or packed red blood cell transfusion
the negative about getting just a plasma transfusion it can be a negative with any blood transfusion is
that you can develop an immune reaction to it not that you're getting the wrong type of blood but
that you are getting different blood and it can contain antibodies and it can spark an immune reaction
which can take away from your immune system's ability to fight cancer so it's not recommended
to get something unless you absolutely need it but you're typically not going to get
or have a recommendation of a blood transfusion unless your hemoglobin is you know 7.5
or below so it wouldn't even be in the cards but certainly if your hemoglobin is that well
bleeding or transfusion is most likely the that is really the best thing to do when you can function
you can you know keep it over as long as that you're going to have a lot of chlorovidities for
signs and symptoms and by highly recommend it to give transfusion but you know you can't have negative
outcomes of getting a transfusion it could also
feel fun you know especially if the person has a chlorovidity of a immune reaction too so you
got to be right next question if I have the heat rod sticker sold in your store on my cell phone
to reduce EFS remember the heat rod doesn't reduce EFS it changes the EFS so that there's a negative
factor to you that's really what the independent studies show on those so if you had an EFS
feeder it would still show high electricity from your phone but it transforms those EFS so they're
not as dangerous for you do those expire or ever need to be replaced no they don't they don't
wear out unless you damage it so no as long as it's you know you know you didn't damage it on the
folder something like that you think will last forever so that's a good deal what I use the right
at night I do not feel anything going out of my body but when I do a foot bath I do feel slight
pains in my liver area where I have a test assist is that the foot bath program is better
hitting the cancer no I wouldn't say so if I think that both the you know the both of them are
beneficial the foot bath program is using higher different frequencies so that's where you may
heal it differently I don't think that you know I created a video that talked about this before
about good pain bad pain with cancer and sometimes when you're running the right and you feel it
I say well that's a good thing but then you it's easy to jump to the conclusion that if that's a
good thing then it must be a bad thing then I don't feel anything and that's not true you know that
you are affecting the cells if you are feeling a little tingling you know that there is some back
there but you don't always feel a tingle when there is a fact so I wouldn't I wouldn't jump to the
conclusion that the foot bath programs are doing better than my ball programs they're different frequencies
some of the same frequencies but some you can get into foot bath you can push higher frequencies
that's part of what's in the foot bath programs so but then there's also detox programs
maybe the detox frequencies that you're feeling in your liver with the foot bath I think I'm
going to move it that maybe how long do I continue to take the homeopath for radiation after
by PET skin what else detoxens the radiation radioactive glucose tracer so I suggest you take
that folio pan for radiation just finish them on because getting radiation and radioactive elements
out of your body is a lifelong process other things that can help pull out radiation and things
are just other keylaters the biggest thing that's going to pull out any toxins from your body
are going to be just supporting your liver phase one two three so go back to the phases of detoxification
information you can even go to the seven phases of detox course and understand the phase one two three
of your liver make sure you're having good moments I know the person that asked this still having
trouble try to get those under control if you're not you know really supporting those seven phases
of detox well you're not going to get anything out of the tissues because if it does get into the
bloodstream and it circulates and it can't get through the liver because the liver is too crowded
that it's just going to be deposited somewhere else in the body that it even if it does get pulled out
in there through chelation and bit dumped back into the one through the lymph system circulates around
if the liver is too crowded it's going to circulate again and it's going to be down somewhere else
so you know supporting all the phases of detoxification is really the key to detoxifying anything so
just just go back to that seven phases detox and make sure that you start at phase six and go back
it's I just heard of getting a blood test for galactic three is this something that we should try
well it can be we do have that blood test available in the lab store it's through
to take us through Boston labs does it um and you could order it it's not super expensive it's like
I want to say it's about 35 bucks or something like that um collected the re is um
um um is it enzyme in your body and it can be the higher levels I think the normal
collected three you want to keep it under like 17 if it's in the high teens or in the 20s at high
level of glutton three leads to ill health not just cancer but it was initially information about
glutton three was about heart disease and it was used as a marker to show up a person had a
heart attack or not um but now it's been implicating in other diseases it can be high at autoimmune
disease it certainly can be high in cancers and if you can get your glutton three levels down
it's been shown in uh in some studies and hypothesized with different doctors uh you're going to have
you're going to fare much better um how do you get collected three levels down well again the
biggest thing is supporting all your detox pathways so um I don't know Dr Isaacs is
big into modified centers packed in and I've been big into modified centers packed in as well
I write about collections read in most out fighting cancer book and we recommend modified
centers packed in for a lot of people from a nutritional standpoint key laders um anything
let's get a help support liberty toxicification is going to help reduce elective three levels
modified centers packed in as one of those key laders that has been shown time to time again to be
one of the best things to bring down elective three levels do you have to measure it um that is
there's some disagreement in philosophies about that because you can do a measurement of
glyctin three at some of us stage four breast cancer and their glyctin three levels are you know
way below normal so the idea is well then that's not an issue but it can be an issue even if somebody's
glyctin three levels are below normal because it depends on how they're expressed in the tissue
um in question so you you're only when you're measuring glyctin three you're measuring blood
levels it can be different in the tissue so um now I would say that if a person has elevated
glyctin three levels in the blood then most likely they have elevated glyctin three levels in the tissue
um but I would say that elevated glyctin three levels in the blood are more indicative of
heart issues and epithelial damage um then they are as being a bigger player with the cancer
that's why I typically don't have it recommended people doing a test um just take modified
centers packed in just work of your liver detox pathways so um that goes you know we've done that
with really every cancer patient not maybe they're not all uh modified centers packed in but
literally everybody was working on their detox pathways so um but you can run the test it's an
inexpensive test to run um but remember glyctin three is a target protein we need to it will go
up with inflammation and it will change quite quickly that's the other negative about
measuring it if you're in a state of inflammation let's say you're uh let's say it's your epithelial
tissue or your cancer that is currently inflamed your glyctin three levels will go up well literally
if you call it down with other means it can change in a matter of hours so the blood test
is um can jump all over the place um and that's why a lot of doctors don't like to even measure it
they'll just treat it um because it can be high and then you can run it the next day and it could be
low and and it's like so it's and isn't a good marker looking at the blood levels it's questionable
I know there's argument it's certainly spark a person if it's high to then do something about it
but it can also give a person a false like oh I'm fighting I'm doing really good
if it's with the normal or it's low so positive negative is every test um but that's the that's
what the measure is up to three um versus like two or markers I mean two markers can can spike
with the cancer growing but it's not going to change day by day um you're going to see
two markers go up and the cancer is growing and you know they'll they can go up sharply
but then you run it if you run another blood test next week they're not going to go down
sharply well you can see that my collectance rate it could be a little bit confusing
okay question on the chat in the last few weeks my face is very red
is this rosacea what is the reason is it connected to gut health
well certainly then you could you could google pictures of rosacea and see if
if your redness looks like a rosacea ranch um if if you can you look at those google pictures of
rosacea it goes oh my gosh that's exactly what it looks like then you know that it's age
pylori so age pylori is the cause of rosacea and there can be other reasons for a red face
that isn't age pylori and because it isn't rosacea so getting a proper diagnosis
would be in order so if you don't feel comfortable going to to google and looking at pictures
then getting into a practitioner that could identify
a rosacea maybe go into the psychologist would be in order but if it is rosacea then it is
age pylori is that a gut issue well yes it no I mean age pylori starts in the gut but it doesn't
necessarily stay in the gut again that's the problem with doing a test for age pylori you got
you know three main ways to test for age pylori you could do the urea breath test that will be
positive if you have age pylori elevated in the stomach maybe in the first part of the cell
or the first part of the duanda but if it's not elevated in the stomach anymore
and it's elevated in the intestinal tract then a stool sample
testing for age pylori which are positive if it's not elevated in the stomach anymore not
elevated in the intestinal tract then the urea breath test and the stool sample maybe negative
the other test is the anti body test the test is kind of useless because that will be elevated
that's that's typically just an iGG test I don't think they have an iG on test for age pylori I
haven't seen that maybe they do now so that's just going to test past exposure it doesn't super
high elevated enough to give you clues of courage exposure so you have to look at other factors as well
if you had a history of age pylori then the knowledge that the fact that it could
very well and very most commonly can will go systemic and affect other parts of the body the
skin is very common it's rosacea we can cause by age pylori but if you look cause other skin
rashes i had patients where had some weird rash all the way down just their left arm there was a
weird case i didn't know what it was when i looked at it certainly looked anything like rosacea
didn't have it and all other decker face tested them and it was rosacea and it was death
rosacea it was age pylori and we treated for age pylori literally the rash went away in a few days
just could boy going on high dose mercury and garlic and real things that you would do for age pylori
but if you have systemic age pylori then you just have to assume that it's affecting
your endothelial cells and that's the worst case scenario so i mean of course worst case scenario
be age pylori and cosy cancer but age pylori does cause cancer it's a double one causes systemic cancer
it's a common cause in prostate cancer and other cancers as well but it is one of the most common
cause of endothelial disorder so causing damaging inflammation to the lining of your arteries
and of course you know you all want to get rid of cancer or we don't want to die of heart disease
while we're waiting to try to get rid of cancer so i'm from of the firm belief that everybody should
treat themselves as if they have age pylori at least in a pulse that the needy that i'll take
are para clear which is a great age pylori killer because it's got it in a form which here
is great i guess because i take it it's got different parasite things like black walnut or regano
or regano is actually good for age pylori where would a clove garlic is really good clove is
really good for liver parasites liver foods garlic powder which is really good for all parasites
good for cancer good for your heart and good for killing age pylori and it's got slippery elm
bark which is really good to help heal your gut it's got kaskara subrata which is good for your gut
violet golden seal which is good for age pylori grapefruit seed extract which is good for
age pylori also good for multiple other parasites barberry root which is good for age pylori in a
source of burberry so i take that not daily but regularly and i also take burberry very regularly so
my favorite things for age pylori i think everybody should be knowledgeable about age pylori that's
why i tell people to read the blog post on helical vector pylori and things to do to deal with it
and follow those steps i think everybody needs to address that whether you have cancer or not
because it is just so prevalent and i don't want you as a cancer patient to
have a heart attack it's you know it's easy to be bottle minded single minded on our focus
of treated cancer and we have other co-orbidities that could you know cause us health so we have to be
reminded about that okay that was all the questions that came in so i'll wait a few minutes
if you guys have any other questions make sure you check them in even before the mastectomy almost
none of my cancer markers came back high i ran four of them 15 CA 153 was a little high
once in the normal the next three times 19 dot CEA we're always doing this 27 29 was a little
high and always there but so i did do i just run the CA 27 29 for one
i wouldn't because you know cancer markers i mean if you know so cancer markers can be a good
way to test progress of your therapy but again there it's not perfect because not all cancer as
will will spew out the protein you know person could be have raging stage 4 cancer it's still not
spew out any of those proteins and so all their cancer markers are normal so they're not it's not a
perfect test just like i said no test is going to be perfect but you know especially if you know you have
a basically a full remission diagnosis i would still run those maybe every three to six months
is because if there is metastasis that well metastatic tumor can be can release a different cancer
marker than the initial tumor so you'd hate to miss it and cost-wise i just i don't think it's
it's not that much different to do that panel than it is to do one or two of them so
i would run i would run all of them i think that's going to be great of course if they're all
normal then you can spread out how often you drop them so if they're all within normal limits maybe you're
only going to just do a scan every six months or something and again just like every other test you
balance it with with uh you know other signs and symptoms and other lab tests too so it's you
don't just rely on one test supplements and rife would be enough for h pylori with supplements and
rife be enough for h pylori i think it's the question um typically yes so um medical treatment of
h pylori h pylori is a bacteria in antibiotic would be the treatment from a medical doctor for
h pylori now they may not prescribe an antibiotic unless you show positive in either a blood test or
um some of a stool sample test or something like that that they look like um but from a medical
standpoint an antibiotic would be in order if you're going to take an antibiotic remember you always
have to make sure that you take a probiotic with an antibiotic so it will
there's been studies showing that it cuts down the side effects of the antibiotic when you take a
probiotic with the antibiotic um but supplements um that will help kill that and using the right
usually are enough to help kill h pylori yes usually are not to help kill it but i mean i
i don't recall having a person have to go and get an antibiotic for um
so i mean it may have happened i just don't have to remember
depending on what would be the best rife program for bladder infection
um i would have to look up the right uh i don't know if there is a
cystitis program or one that's labeled bladder infection i'd look through the alphabetical
list eat of them if i were you um you can run if it's if most bladder infections have a bacterial
component to them so running bacterial infection any bacterial programs may be helpful
if you've had a test done and know the bacteria then you can look up and see if there's a program
for that bacteria um if you can't find anything um then i would have to i think if you have some labs
that you that show so it's good to get a lab where you they do a smear and they test for what
culture it is so getting a culture to know what exactly their treating would be helpful if i can find
frequencies for that bacteria or fungus or um there's kandita programs for sure other rife already
that i will that i could write a program um but um um uh yeah so if you can't find something on the right
let me know that i might be able to create a program for you can't always if there's no
adult frequencies for a specific bacteria but if there are no frequencies in the program it hasn't been
created then i can do it here should therapy recommends a no salt diet is this how we should be eating
um i don't think so so remember and i write about this in my book as well some of the things that are
in the the gurshin therapy that are go way back from in the 1930s and 40s when Max Gerson wrote his book
so if you read Max Gerson's book you'll read things about absolutely nobody should be taking salt
everybody should be on potassium things like that that were a part of his original program
was charlie version has not changed anything from Max Gerson's original original program some doctors
that worked with her for a number of years i know a German doctor that worked with her for a number of
years and just trying to get her to go let's come into the 21st century here there's more data
there's more research she just absolutely refused um she stays true to his program and there's good
things and bad things about them but i do think there's benefit of looking at new research and new data
it can both prove that the efficacy of some of the things that you've done but it can also
disgroup some of the things that you've done and we as practitioners need to stay humble and that
new data comes out and we've got to go wow this is really interesting i need to start testing for
this or start applying this or boy what i was doing now i don't think was really correct
and we need to be humble enough to change that um that goes for all of us uh so as far as a
dose of diet i don't think so though i will say with salt there are some people there's a percentage
of the population that is salt sensitive uh that has been proven with with with uh research around
autoimmune disease and research around blood pressure and coronary heart disease some people that are
sodium sensitive um uh will as sodium chloride will attach to receptors in the smooth muscle
underneath the epithelial and cause contraction and increased blood pressure but uh the studies that
i saw about two thirds of the people are not sodium sensitive that it causes um engagement with
that receptor in it and sodium doesn't increase blood pressure but when that with some of that
initial research came out that's when you know they started saying back in the 70s and 80s then all
high blood pressure people should live at their sodium that's only true in a percentage of population
of coronary patients that sodium sensitive there's also a sodium sensitivity as sodium can bind to
um um uh receptors on immune cells and cause immune uh people with autoimmune disease to worsen
especially with Hashimoto's um i write about that information and i think i've actually
created video on it by the clinic disease and all of you in course in the last module what i
talked more specifically about Hashimoto's and autoimmune thyroid that is um relatively new
information um and people with Hashimoto's many of them that have that sodium sensitivity
for their thyroid gland do much better at taking um chidose potassium before their meals
um and for many people it's just calm down their triggers immensely it's more information on
the module six i think it is on the autoimmune cause but but i don't i don't think i see i don't think
for most people with cancer that they have to be on a no salt diet next question does the safe
sleep work the same way the heat run does for e-MF protection
no so the heat run can help the e-MFs that are coming off your bone to be less damaging to you
the safe sleep locks e-MFs so two different things there so you could use both a heat run i have a
heat run on my bone and i use it safely um and i almost never put my phone up to my ear to talk
right do i use my phone almost always either in the car or the speaker or speaker phone
not put it up to my ear so you want to keep the e-MFs you know away from you as much as possible
the safe sleep blocks the e-MFs so with the safe sleep you can close the um front face of it
and still talk on the phone up to your ear it's going to block a good degree of e-MFs
and that if you want to you know completely block the e-MFs from your phone you could put it in
let's call it a fair day cage fair day cages a term um uh that it means that you're putting it in
some type of sleep or or compartment that blocks all e-MFs blocks all frequencies um you will be able
to receive phone calls or text once in that so we have those they're super cheap i think they're
fifteen dollars there there's fabric double fabric um sleeves that are a little bit bigger than
your phone that you can slip your phone into and you're basically putting your phone to sleep so you're
not going to be able to receive phone calls and you're not going to be able to receive text but you
will deduct it getting e-MFs from it um so there's benefits to doing that at different times like
you can still put the charging cord outside the phone you don't have to close up the sleeve and
you can charge your phone at night um without getting any e-MFs or it's better just to keep it close
away from it is it greens first or the sun's background that has submit a need to be taken
take it an hour away from plenty of time um medicine it's the greens first that has submit
and you're really about 30 minutes away from plenty of time so be good um and remember the most
common mistake that people make with plenty of time is they take it you know in the morning really
brush their teeth and usually toothpaste has some sort of unique component to it um but the
greens first regular first excuse me original which is the green one has a new tinted and other
questions all right well thank you all and then once you guys all next week you have anything else
if you think of make sure you get it on our uh question on the website or any to your media
reaction call the clinic too all right bless you guys love you all let's see you next week